this is clinical
decision making of the
cognitively impaired
or acute psychotic
patient assessment
of capacity and
civil commitment i'm
dr jeffrey goldberg
today i have a case
for you where imagine
you're consulted to
evaluate an adult male with
a history of bipolar
disorder who is admitted
to a medical unit for
kidney failure the
internal medicine team
tells you his condition
is severe and he
needs urgent dialysis.
Each time you try
and talk to him about
his condition or a
procedure, he curses.
He orders you to
leave him alone and
he says he's fine.
You go to the bedside
and you begin your
capacity evaluation.
You first assess his
understanding by asking
him if he knows why
he's in the hospital
and how the doctors
are trying to help
him, but all you get
from him is, I don't
care. Maybe it's something
about my kidneys.
He can't elaborate
any further, nor
can he say what the
treatment would be.
Does this patient
have capacity?
What are your
next steps? How
do you proceed
from this point?
Here are your session
objectives, where
we're going to
cover some of these
answers. And we're also
going to talk about,
from the starting
point, of what are
admitted patients'
rights, because patients
have the right to
object treatment.
And these admitted
patient rights really
pertain to patients on
inpatient psychiatric
units, as well as
general medical units.
The right to quality
care, of course, the
right to object to
treatment, the right
to be free of restraint
and seclusion, unless
there's a safety
reason involved, the
right to have
correspondence, telephone,
and visitors. And in
the handout from the
New York State Office
of Mental Health,
you'll see a lot of
these rights elaborated.
let's move right along
to what is a civil
commitment and the
bipolar patient the
patient with bipolar
disorder that I
described at the
beginning might very well
warrant at some point
in his admission
a civil commitment
that means being
committed to an inpatient
psychiatric unit
in many states
including new york state
uh and elsewhere civilly
committed commitment
encompasses a
voluntary versus an
involuntary admission
that is you can recognize
that you may have
the need for mental
health treatment
and sign yourself in
or it may be done on
an involuntary basis
In New York State,
there are two types of
involuntary admissions.
One is an emergency
admission where a
physician, doesn't
have to be a
psychiatrist, a physician
can admit you to the
hospital and then
within 48 hours, a
second licensed physician
certifies the need
for that admission.
An additional way
to do it is to
have two
physicians, again,
doesn't have to
be a psychiatrist,
sign and state
that you need to be
admitted to an inpatient
psychiatric unit.
So actually, there's
a couple ways where
you could lose
your freedom in the
U.S. You could
criminally, or you could
be civilly committed
psychiatrically.
Out of the codes
that go from
state to state,
they vary.
This is from Arkansas
in terms of what
their criteria is for
civil commitment, and
it basically states
that a person will
be eligible for
involuntary admission if
he or she is in such
a mental condition
as a result of mental
illness, disease,
or disorder that he
or she poses a clear
and present danger to
himself or others. And
that is the operative
phrase in New York,
in Arkansas, and
virtually everywhere.
You can be involuntarily
committed if
as a result of your
mental illness or
condition that you
pose a clear and
present danger to
yourself or others.
It's a reference in
the CPG put out by the
Arkansas Treatment
Advocacy Center, which
goes into civil
commitment laws that have
established different
criteria for commitment.
now just being
committed to a hospital
doesn't mean that you
uh are incompetent
that you don't have
uh the legal ability
to make decisions
for yourself remember
you retain all your
life or your rights
you have the right
to refuse medication
even on a psychiatric
unit you have the
right to refuse
electroconvulsive therapy
none of this could be
forced against your
will with the
exception of medication
only in an emergency
situation when there's
imminent danger to
yourself or others
there's a landmark
case in new york called
the rivers versus
cats decision it was
issued by the new
york court of appeals
in 1986 and it established
that involuntary
psychiatric patients
have a constitutional
right to refuse
psychiatric medication
unless the state can
prove the medication
is necessary and
that the patient
lacks capacity to make
informed decisions
so we're going to
get into what it does
mean to lack capacity
the court ruled that
forcibly medicating
a patient without due
process violates their
constitutional rights
under the new york
state constitution but
at the same time the
state recognized that
it has an interest in
treating individuals
who may be a danger
to themselves or
others. So as a result,
the ruling established
legal standards
requiring a judicial
hearing, a judicial hearing
before administering
medication without
consent. And what's
the exception? Except
in emergency situations.
So a person on an
inpatient psychiatric
unit who's dangerous
to themselves or
others imminently can
get a one-time stat dose.
But ongoing treatment
with medication
against their objection
has to be done with
due process through a
judicial hearing. And
actually in New York
State, there's what
we call mental health
court where these
patients go before a
judge and have due process
and state their
reasons for objecting.
This decision, the
Rivers v. Katz decision,
strengthened patient
autonomy and due
process protections
in New York State's
mental health system.
So at the same
time, while we're
treating patients and we
want them to be
empowered and we want
patient autonomy, we
also have to protect
patients who
might be a danger
to themselves
or to others.
The decision goes on
to say that you have
to show that the patient
lacks capacity, and
we're going to get
into what that means,
that it has to be due
to a mental illness,
that they're likely
to benefit from the
treatment, and that
there's no less
restrictive treatment
available. So it
has to have all
those elements before
we can go ahead and
medicate someone on
a regular basis over
their objection.
So let's get into the
capacity determination
itself. And again,
there's a very
good article in the CPG,
the class preparation
guide of how do
I determine if my
patient has decision
-making capacity. So
I want you definitely
to take a look at
that. But the first
step is in determining
a patient's capacity,
their ability to
make clinical decisions
for themselves.
The first step is
recognizing, do
they have a mental
illness or do
they have psychosis,
depression?
Are they
cognitively impaired
due to developmental
disorder?
Or might they have
dementia, delirium?
Are they acutely
intoxicated?
Once that determination
is made, that
there's an underlying
condition, we go
ahead and make the
capacity determination,
again, using these
four elements.
First thing is, does
the patient have a
choice, right? Do
they express a choice?
Do they communicate
a choice?
The second thing is,
do they understand
the relevant
information, right? Do
they have a factual
understanding of
what's happening?
and then do they
appreciate the situation
and its consequences
and then finally
are they able to
manipulate the
information in a rational
fashion do they reason
rationally so let's go
back to our our bipolar
patient who's magnetic
dialysis right um he
clearly is communicating
a choice doesn't want
the treatment and
maybe he even has some
vague understanding
right that uh the um
it has something to do
with my kidneys so
that's even questionable
whether he has complete
understanding where
we could even give him
that uh but maybe at
this point he doesn't
appreciate the seriousness
and the situation
and its consequences
uh maybe he thinks yes
i all understand that
but that applies to
the patient in the next
bed not not to me
and clearly so far in
the evaluation of that
patient. He's not able
to show that he's
weighing the pros and cons
if he has dialysis
versus if he doesn't.
He's not able to reason
rationally and manipulate
the information in
a rational fashion.
So this case, if a
patient, say, is refusing
medication or refusing
dialysis or some
other serious treatment
on an inpatient service,
inpatient psychiatric
service. In New
York State, they get
represented by a lawyer.
They have due
process. And the
Supreme Court of
New York hears all
the patients' requests
for medication
or treatment
over objection.
They even hear patient
requests for
discharge, right?
Involuntary patients
are civilly committed.
And if they can,
they can request a
court hearing for
their discharge.
So deeper dive
into what are
the myths about capacity.
And I used the term
competency before, but
capacity and competency
are not the same.
Capacity is a
clinical term, right?
It's a capacity to
make an informed
decision about a
medical procedure.
Competency is a legal
determination, you
know, by a judge after
due process in the legal
system. Is the person
competent to stand
trial? Is the person
competent to make a will?
Is the person competent
to enter a contract
that's different than
clinical capacity?
um if the patient decides
the bipolar patient
i want to sign out
against a medical advice
just because a person
says that does not
mean just because
they're disagreeing with
your treatment decision
doesn't mean that they
lack decision-making
capacity again you
have to go through uh
the four elements of
decision-making capacity
communicating a choice
understanding the
information, appreciating
the situation, and
reasoning rationally.
Myth number three,
there's no need to
assess decision
-making capacity unless
a patient goes against
medical advice.
Let's go back to our
bipolar patient again
with urgently needing
dialysis. Should he
go along with it,
and you just proceed
with the dialysis, that
would be a mistake.
You cannot go ahead
and proceed with the
dialysis or similar
serious treatment just
because the patient
goes along with it um
myth number four uh
decision making capacity
is all or nothing so
sometimes patients
come in and they have
electrolyte imbalances
they're they're intoxicated
uh or they haven't
begun treatment yet
for the underlying
condition and then a day
later uh a few days
later and even a few
hours later, the person
can clear up. So it's
not simply that once
the person determination
is made that they
lack capacity, it
remains constant throughout
the whole period.
Also, some patients
have the ability to have
capacity for simple
things like agree to
go for a chest x-ray,
agree to take an EKG.
But when it gets
to be more serious
and there's higher
risk involved,
then we kind of discern
out in different
levels what
capacity might mean.
Just because a person is
cognitively impaired,
number five,
doesn't mean that they
lack decision-making
capacity. Again, maybe
the person with the
bipolar disorder who
might be manic, who
needs the urgent dialysis,
he may have ability
to decide for, you
know, simple requests
like maybe simple lab
tests or imaging. But in
terms of going for,
again, the dialysis,
it requires a more
comprehensive assessment.
Number seven, patients
who have not been
given relevant
information about their
condition can lack
decision-making capacity.
So I see this a lot.
Many times we're called
to determine capacity,
determinations in
patients, and it really
has to do with the
fact that the patients
have not been
communicated well by the
surgical team or the
medical team that's
carrying them. They
haven't been given all
the facts and no one's
really sat down with
them and they're
kind of in the dark.
And just because they
haven't been given
the relevant information,
we can't say, oh,
that they lack decision
-making capacity.
Number eight, patients
with certain psychiatric
disorders lack decision
-making capacity
all patients with
psychiatric disorders
uh admitted not admitted
everyone who comes
in who we treat is
assumed to have decision
-making capacity even
the acutely psychotic
patient when they get
on the inpatient unit
the basic assumption
and everyone is starting
out that they have
capacity uh and if
we need to do something
over their objection.
We have to go through
the steps of due
process and go through
the steps of the domain,
the four domains of
decisional capacity.
So that speaks
to number nine,
just because you're
hospitalized,
every patient, they
do not lose their
capacity. They're
not deemed legally
incompetent by the
virtue of being civilly
committed on an inpatient
psychiatric unit.
And that's a common
misconception. Oh,
they're committed,
they're incompetent, that
they don't have the
right to make their own
decisions. That's a
common misconception.
All institutionalized
patients, all
psychiatric inpatients
are presumed to have
decision-making
capacity until proven
or shown otherwise.
And then number 10,
only psychiatrists
or psychologists
can assess decision
-making capacity.
Not so. In fact,
the treating
doctor, whether
they be a surgeon,
internist, obstetrician,
emergency physician
who's been working with
the patient, you're
actually in a better
position and have
better knowledge and
better contact with the
patient than the
consulting psychiatrist.
You're in the best
position to assess the
decision-making
capacity of the patient.
And these myths
are covered more
extensively in
the accompanying
article. So again,
just to recap,
the takeaway is the four
domains of
decisional capacity,
communication
of a choice,
relevant information
as understood, right
that uh the person
appreciates the
situation that that
they appreciate the
seriousness of it and
that it pertains to them
and then they're able
in a uh reasonable
rational manner to
uh manipulate the
information in a
rational manner see we
managed to to uh put
in an osteopathic
theme, even in the
capacity determination,
right, even in
the four domains,
to be able to manipulate
information in a
rational manner.
And this concludes the
lecture on capacity
determination and
the civil commitment.